I started to get hives like huge welts
on my body and like really itchy algal
is probably killing me I should probably
stop drinking I'm Zoe
I'm Kevin I'm Julie and I glow
some Asian people have a hard time
processing alcohol but not all Asian
people but definitely me they lack an
enzyme which helps you get rid of the
alcohol after you drink it you feel hot
and flushed and very uncomfortable it
kind of feels like these needles are
prickling my skin my eyes get really red
my nose gets really stuffed up makes
like horrible I wish I didn't have it
but that's my life I met this guy and we
were like hitting it off we decided to
go to a bar so two hours before today I
took pepcid ac which is an antacid and
it's supposed to help you get rid of
Asian glow it's worked in the past but
just in case I knew that I should also
have something else from like this
random website I had ordered a special
elixir that was supposed to get rid of
Asian glow the nutrients are just like a
bunch of random vitamins and stuff so I
figured it would work after the first
drink I start feeling a little weird so
I went to the bathroom and I'm like holy
my skin is gonna fall off this guy's
gonna think I'm crazy cuz I'm scratching
everywhere if you're kind of bad for the
guy so I like splash water on my face
and try to cool down as long as I stay
nice and cool I'll be all right I should
have called it at that point but I was
just like you know what I'm having fun
I'm just gonna keep at it but my face is
super super red and feels like it's
burning I see my glass of ice water in
front of me and I'm just like oh my gosh
I would feel so nice if I just poured it
all over my head before I can even stop
myself I just like I pour it all over my
head and if she's so good all the ice is
like getting down my shirt the redness
and the itchiness in my mind is going
away my dates they're just staring at me
like I'm crazy and you're like you
should leave and so I left I checked the
guy just to see what was up and he
responded and she's like yeah had a
fun time but I think I want to explore
other options and that was the last I
heard of him if you're out there sorry
so I was traveling through Birmingham
Alabama and it was late at night and I
had gone up to this bar with my friend
cuz he wanted to hook up with some guy I
was guided to being his wingman and then
we're at the bar I've had like half a
glass I realized that my friend had
abandoned me I need to get back to my
hotel it so I'm like it's fine I can
just call a cab the cab never comes so I
start walking the mile and I realize
downtown Birmingham is not that safe
there's all these people like coming at
me and I'm like it's fine I'm a grown-up
I can run so I start running and then
all of a sudden this guy jumps out at me
he's like stop there's like three cop
cars around me and they're all like
coming out of their cars and I'm just
standing there like I don't know what I
did I don't know what I did and I
realized that they just saw this random
red-faced Asian guy running down the
street and they full-on thought that I
was like super high that I was a drug
dealer but after I started talking
because I have this voice they were like
he's just a gay Asian guy he's fine I
got so mad at my friend did you have a
fun night do you hook up you got laid
because I was surrounded by police this
is the problem with having asianglow
once I was at a bar I was with my other
Asian friends we pass around a thing of
zantac like okay it's gonna be a real
fun night and then a bartender comes
over and it's like guys I gotta kick you
out I can't have you doing xanax in my
bar oh oh no we're not taking xanax it's
zantac no for just doing antacids and he
was like antacids okay our food is fine
but if you want to take an antacid then
okay and then we all laughed all the
confusion was cleared we ordered our
drinks there we ended up staying we had
a great time after all and asianglow was
avoided it's okay to have a asianglow
like there's a lot of people that have
it be proud of it just be red don't try
to get rid of it like I did
don't ask us questions just buy us a
beer so now I don't drink
[Music]